you guys talked about Matty Healy
recently we did but I don't listen it's
fair yeah I love them and I love him
I've got uh
did I kiss him yeah that was crazy huh
yeah but I would like to I'd like to add
something because I was listening to
those episodes and I was like if they
just knew if they just understood so can
I Enlighten you sure yeah so there's a
history about Maddie Healy kissing fans
and being a nuisance on stage sure sure
so there's a long-standing history
within the fandom of like he used to be
very like struggled with addiction very
badly and in the Golden Era of 2013 2014
like Tumblr you know chokers all that
sort of stuff he this is off to a good
start it's off to a great teenagers with
chokers yep all right go ahead we were
all like 16 17 and we had just found
them and it was like you know just angst
in a bottle was pretty much their music
and he was this skinny coked out white
guy on stage British and like he would
body a bottle of wine while he was
performing he was on heroin he was like
really strung out badly
and he would do that he would pull
people up on stage and make out with him
and it was just like oh tortured artist
and so that was kind of like we have
that in our minds from back then and
it's a nostalgic thing because he was so
deeply unwell right
he got clean
yes doesn't he still get [ __ ] up on
stage well let me let me finish and so
he got clean he got all the heroin
um cleaned up his life and he's like in
his 30s now and he's you want to say
something so bad no let me finish no
you're giggling
we all know that like he struggled with
this now he's clean
um and his music reflects that well now
because they're back on tour he is all
about like self referential and like
being hyper self-aware of his cringe and
this and that and it's all very meta and
so he's doing this on stage as a sort of
performance art because it's nostalgic
for all of us to be like oh yeah you
used to be [ __ ] up and do this but
it's also self-referential because he
knows that that was very damaging but
it's also what people want so he's
playing the rock star giving the people
what they want but also he knows it so
he's the smartest person ever so he's
not getting Drunk On Stage no it's a bit
I mean there could be liquor in there
but he's not like stumbling drunk addict
the way that he used to so that's
there's a lot of context that goes into
it where people like y'all see on their
life they're like why is she [ __ ]
kissing girls I want to do that yeah I'm
still wondering why he
yeah I'm just not so yeah you don't get
it it's different when you're tongue to
tongue with him like it's so cool it's
what they want if Maddie Healy is like
you've had a poster of him on your wall
since you were 14. it's like you're 24
now and you're like kiss me and he's
like okay
that
yeah or you're freshly 18.
or you're lying so you're telling us
this dude is a [ __ ] Platinum groomer
is that what you're saying no what
you guys don't [ __ ] get it you don't
get it you just start listening when
you're 12. no and you wait no no you I
started talking you tuned out because
you said a woman's talking no no no I I
heard what you said just none of it made
me feel better about
we're all 16 wearing chokers it was a
different time in the crowd and you know
who all says that Republicans when they
talk about [ __ ] teenagers
y'all are gonna cut this into an edit
that's like me being a republican
apologist I'm gonna be like never going
on that [ __ ] show again no we don't
we don't we don't do that we do do that
no we won't do that okay literally do do
I'm gonna take a note let's this is a
good clip right here yeah so cut all
this yeah yeah no but it's you know well
actually you don't know what I mean it's
in the mindset of a fan girl who has I'm
not kidding like Maddie Healey's been a
part of my life for like 12 years so
this kissing thing is not a new thing no
it's absolutely not a new thing and now
he's doing it as a bit that's what you
need to know it's a bit got it
but it's also where it's also doing the
exact same thing like it's yeah but it's
like legal now
[Laughter]
cracked out now
no you got ta you can consent that's
what makes it fine
he's sober that's what makes it okay it
does like an a
so the way he knows who he's gonna he
knows who's gonna kiss
on stage yes see you don't even know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah get out of here get out of here
you're [ __ ] wrong Mike you know what
[ __ ] mean
[ __ ] [ __ ]
if you love your fans
have sex with them
what's Difficult about that
[ __ ] figure it out no it's it's like
because
what they want and now they're of age
Britney's just fighting for her [ __ ]
life right now to be like no it's not
it's normal it's normal the fans and the
comments are gonna be like she's right
they will we'll find out we'll see
Broski Nation let's do a check-in
this image is so brutal
he's like this idea is like
[Music]
it's printed vertically on a horizontal
good enough
stop me loving in that loud movie or
something uh [ __ ] it
sounded like it was good thanks
so what was it like meeting Harry Styles
do you really want to know kind of I'm
I'm interested I mean you're bonding you
and me are fighting are we fighting
we're gonna have it out in the parking
lot later listen
it was a test
oh are we doing bonus today too
I don't know what's on [ __ ] Monday I
don't really usually record today so I
don't know what are we supposed to do a
bonus we're supposed to but you know
I'm here I'm yours today are you really
yeah so you'll stick around yeah you
will of course you don't mind all right
change the lighting Luke
it's fine yeah this is some real bone
Zone discussion no Maddie Healy checking
IDs and kissing fans is so cool it's
literally a bit and when he kisses oh
well stop fighting with me you're making
me feel bad
huh
I'm not fighting look I'm just
hey
I'm just saying you see that haters
mine doesn't reach
short ass arms sorry that was mean I'm
just saying as you know
I just I gotta push back you know oh no
please this is great we're gonna go on
tour together yeah fist fight yeah we're
gonna box no no no no it's not gonna be
like that we're gonna go on tour and
we're just gonna have a big room full of
people like all right she thinks it's
normal I'm not really
is disgusting the Matty healing it's
just a thousand two thousand people be
like no it's fine no you don't get it
all right get up here
I'm telling you all the comments are
gonna agree if you just want to kiss
your fans Brittany you don't have to
normalize it I want to kiss my fans no
no my fans are trying to kiss Jack in
and they don't want me damn yeah damn
it's a harsh reality I live
this is CR is he sucking finger okay
this happened a few days ago and I don't
want to talk about it oh all right you
know all right you know you don't get
them you don't get the pick and choose
Bridget this is your boy this is your
boy Britney's like he's back on heroin I
think it's fun he's uh I don't wanna I
prefer not to comment does she have a
stocking on her thumb you guys aren't
thinking about her she won damn he's
sucking thumb
Brittany that's crazy you cannot sit
here and tell me that that's not crazy
this wave between
crazy people and no
jail Predator it's a very thin line he
rides the line between like being ironic
and like post irony and Being Earnest as
a musician yeah and so he people want
him to be you are giggling so much
he also wants to do this yeah
no regardless of that if he didn't want
to be doing this he would not you know
what else he's single and he did not
used to do this when he was in a
relationship that's so good of him
yeah that's kind of working against her
point we're really proud of him yeah
we're really proud of him Maddie Healy I
know you're watching and I believe you
and I I believe what you're doing
I think what you're doing is uh I'm down
with it why is he eating that girl's
prolapse that's so crazy dude
next week new pictures of Matty Healy
service oh whoa oh he's rubbing prolapse
I'm just crazy but some girls like
prolapse in the air
[Laughter]
that's a meat Canyon [ __ ] sketch
right there I would like to kiss your
butthole
my butthole extends
that's the robes I've been looking for
no you don't understand Maddie he used
to do this way back in the day he was a
kiss prolapses and
that's literally what's going on listen
Brittany I'm bullying you like an older
brother because I'm not gonna let you
[ __ ] get it no I'm not gonna let your
young ass come up in here and be like no
you don't get it he's like kissing fans
it's a bit I'm not gonna let you do that
that's fair no no listen listen in just
to play Devil's Advocate here's a funny
one that's also really hard to defend
slow slow ties spitting in fans mouths
yeah oh is he does that something he
still does he hasn't been on the road
for a minute right right he had a kid
but when he was doing slow tie this
English rapper oh God every every every
you know a lot of hip-hop heads would be
like yo slow top [ __ ] great artists
you know I think soul ties a great
artist too when he was doing that I was
like whoa [ __ ] young blood did that
[ __ ] too remember that right out oh yeah
pandemic ended yeah he was like spitting
his hand rubbing on his hair and
spitting on the crowd and I was like
that is awful yeah that's a that's a
move oh let's see it oh you're kidding
that's very sexual that is [ __ ] but
they asked me no you're right it's what
they want they hold up and I bet I bet
he didn't do an age check
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all right
oh did you
18 perfect
she holds up as positive
you [ __ ] oh God I hope you're all
right with this
wow oh I do listen I see what you're
saying yes
I get it okay but it's just different